okay so marvel's eternals is one of the
most divisive mcu movies ever made
though it was the first film to receive
a rotten rating on rotten tomatoes i
actually really liked the movie and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the best easter eggs in it
to hopefully give you a new appreciation
for the film now the movie starts off
with a block of text that fills in a lot
of mythology in the mcu however this
somewhat ties their own myths and
religions in with the lore of the marvel
universe from the very first two
sentences the text opens with the words
in the beginning which is also how the
book of genesis starts however whereas
that sentence in full reads in the
beginning god created the heavens and
the earth the eternals discusses the six
singularities if you cast your mind back
to guardians of the galaxy then you
might remember that the collector
referred to the infinity stones as the
singularities we also saw east on the
searcher in a video and the collector
himself lived inside the celestial head
of nowhere this kinda ties the mcu in
with human history pretty closely and
the name icarus of course also pulls
from myth and legend in the story of
icarus his father daedalus spelled two
pair of wings out of wax and feathers
the pair attempted to fly but icarus
flew too close to the sun which melted
the wax and thus he fell to his death in
the movie we learned that this story was
created by sprite but it somewhat
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy as he
flies into the sun at the end of the
movie athena of course pulls from the
greek goddess athena and their apparent
home planet olympia is also the name of
a place on earth that was regarded as a
sanctuary during ancient grecian times
kingo is playing on kingu from babylon
vastus is playing on the greek god of
the forge havastos cersei inspired
cersei who could transform humans into
animals and both gilgamesh and ajak have
roots in other myths names play a big
part in the movie and when icarus and
cersei visit fastos's home later on he
tells his family that they're isaac and
sylvia this is sylwia
and
isaac
these are the two alter egos that the
pair actually used in the comics in
order to hide their true identities now
they all travel together on the domo
which flies past the sun somewhat
foreshadowing icarus journey into it at
the end of the film now in the comics
icarus did have a son who flew too close
to the sun and he ended up falling to
his death on top of this the domo was
actually also the name of an eternal in
the comics later on we visit the ship to
find makari there and can spot several
artifacts on board this includes the
emerald tablet which first introduced
the concept of as above so below this
has been adapted into several marvel
storylines and it's often used when
characters are delving into the mystical
side of the universe we actually see her
bothering for the emerald tablet during
a scene and several points on the tablet
including the as above so below section
have been obsessed over for centuries
potentially its usage here is a node to
the celestials who exist above us in the
cosmos but also below us in the earth's
core mukhari is of course hiding out
below the planet and there's also the
holy grail of arthurian legend which may
or may not be brought into a future
black knight storyline it's also
mentioned at one point that king arthur
had a crush on dina when she's wielding
excalibur beyond this though is the
ebony blade which potentially shows up
in one of the post-credits scenes in
case you don't know dane whitman is
actually a descendant of the black
knight and the uncle that cersei tells
him to reach out to actually had the
moniker in the comics during the film
cersei gives dane an ancient ring
bearing his family crest and this
actually possesses the symbol of the
black knight on it the black knight was
a fearsome fighter and the ebony blade
actually corrupted him somewhat much
like the one ringing the lord of the
rings it sucked away at someone's life
the more that they used it and it
eventually turned them more ageful and
violent this is why the inscription on
the box reads
as it eventually makes you spiral out of
control until all you want to do is
fight to the death at his birthday party
he mentions all the things that sprite
told him about cersei and this was
actually shown in a deleted scene that
was released exclusively by ign the pair
toured the natural history museum
discussing athena gods cersei man and
the deviants this somewhat pulls from a
section in the comics in which a similar
thing happens and it's a really good
scene that i recommend you go watch
other deleted scenes include makari and
sprite reminiscing over destroyed
civilizations and it's from this hello
and basically doing a nutsack on your
chin is how you say thanos in asl now in
the post-credits scene we also hear our
voice and chloe xiao confirmed that this
is mahershala ali aka blade he says sure
you're ready for that mr whitman and
stops him from touching it so it's going
to be interesting to see if they try and
master the dark power together in the
comics blade and the black knight were
part of a group called mi13 who acted as
paranormal investigators i'd love to see
a new team forming with blade and dane
and we also know that moon knight is
going to have scenes inside a london
museum so potentially it could all be
connected because as i say it's all
connected it's always connected i've
been telling you for months now speaking
of how things are connected we actually
see throughout the film that there are
several nods to captain america's shield
during the bollywood scene we can catch
a similar design with circles and a star
in the middle being used by the dancers
around kingo beyond this though when the
eternals fly in his private airplane we
can see cap's original shield hanging up
beside the bar this pulls from the
comics and it was also used as a prop
during the star spangled man with a
planned musical before steve took it
with him when going out to save bucky
there was also a scene shown in trailers
in which theena was training and you
could catch one being used by the people
that she was going toe-to-toe with early
on in the film the doma arrives on earth
and the monolith structure could be a
nod to 2001 a space odyssey which too
involves one landing on the planet in
that movie this changed the course of
human history much like what the
eternals do and it allowed us to evolve
the deviants somewhat mirror this idea
of evolution and just in the same way
that the fish crawled from the oceans
onto the land we see a deviant monster
climbing out the sea now 2001 a space
odyssey has one of the most famous
cinematic cuts in it of all time and
just in the same way that we jumped
hundreds of thousands of years in an
instant through the use of an object
appearing like another a dagger that
cersei improves is used to take us into
the present this is actually a real-life
dagger that was an earth then a tomb in
air which is a port city of mesopotamia
which is where the opening takes place
at the dagger is held at the natural
history museum in london and here she
walks past the statue of charles darwin
darwin of course pioneered a lot of work
on the theory of evolution further tying
back to humanity growing because of the
eternals he looks over cersei's shoulder
following the next shot as well and
clearly was chosen to be this dominant
in the scene for a reason now as we
talked a lot about in this video blades
play a big part in the movie and at one
point we see sprite looking over one in
cersei's house this actually comes back
around later on and it's the same blade
that sprite uses to stab cersei with
when she's pretending to be ajak
absolutely lost my mind noticing this on
a rewatch and it's such a good carryover
now pink floyd's time plays over the
title sequence and you can catch the
celestials amongst the logos before the
heroes come in showing how imperative
they were now above the ad for the
museum we can see one that says welcome
back and this is by the global
repatriation council or grc for short in
falcon in the winter soldier we learned
that this helped to re-home those
brought back by the blip who found
people either in their jobs or their
houses the text below it says welcome
back we can help and it also features an
image of people hugging which is
iconography that was used in reports
during one division now if you're
enjoying the video so far and want to
give me a hug i'd be eternally grateful
if you hit the thumbs up button and also
subscribe to the channel we do videos
like this all the time and we love to
have you on board as one of the family
so yes come join us as we help to
destroy the world cheers now dane
whitman talks about a poem by walt
whitman and potentially the two may have
been related though we don't find out if
this is the case whitman's work
especially this piece was very
optimistic mirroring humanity's new
outlook since the blip returned the
population that got snapped in this
broad earth of ours amid the measureless
grossness and the slag
enclosed and safe within its central
heart nestles the seed perfection cersei
then talks about apex predators and
discusses how no one is able to hunt
them apex predators do hunt their prey
for food like all predators
but one thing that sets them apart is
that there are no other animals in their
habitat strong enough to hunt them
this is somewhat a metaphor for the
eternals who are pretty much predators
for the planet though they don't realize
it they also fight a deviant in camden
lock which shout out to london yeah i've
i've been there i'll tell you i'll tell
you some stories about that i'd save it
for another video though now here icarus
meets staying for the first time and if
you cast your mind back to game of
thrones when rob said goodbye to jon
snow he said the next time he saw him
that he'd be in black this was of course
a nod to the night's watch but as dane
will be playing the black knight it's a
great little coincidental easter egg now
you might notice that all of the
eternal's powers are golden and this
actually has precedent in the mcu
captain marvel 2 pulled from cosmic
energy and this is why she also appears
to have golden light emanating from
inside of her beyond that though all the
energies and magics in the mcu are
uniformed so that they all have the same
colour scheme your typical magic is
orange chaos magic is red dark energies
are purple ones at all to perception are
green and golden is of course cosmic
also shadow kingo's finger guns pew pew
pew pew now dame brings up doctor
strange when asking if cersei is a
wizard and shouts eric voss from new
rockstars for pointing out that later on
she does turn a lava crater into birds
this somewhat mirrors how strange
reversed one of thanos attacks in
infinity war and turned it into a flock
of butterflies sprite's powers are also
very similar to loki's abilities and
she's able to create doubles at one
point in the bridge when a deviant
attacks if you slow down the footage you
can see that these actually disappear
when she's knocked down which is a
really cool bit of attention to detail
we also get whih news which you might
know as being the fictional news network
from the mcu this is hosted by christine
everhart he did a big spread big spread
on tony stark and iron man and it's
appeared in iron man 2 daredevil one
division and falcon in the winter
soldier at this point we flash back to
babylon and slowly over the film learn
the celestial's true plan this is to
awaken tiamat who in the comics is known
as the sleeping celestial in the comics
he popped about san francisco but here
he's gonna destroy the entire planet he
currently lies beneath the earth waiting
for humans to become intelligent enough
so that they stop doing things like the
bird box challenge and the domo is
located inside the hanging gardens of
babylon this is one of the seven wonders
of the ancient world and yeah that bird
box joke was a bit ancient wasn't it yes
sorry there's there's been nothing
that's happened for the last two years i
had to go back now i am a bit of a crap
breakdowner but i've got someone good in
to explain the legend of teammate and
also babylon hey paul ryan from
screencrash here i'm glad we're finally
getting your take on the eternals as you
know we've already done several videos
breaking down this movie but i recently
read a very cool fact that i missed the
ending where the eternals defeat a
celestial called tiamut is actually
taken from an old babylonian myth see
back in ancient babylon every city
essentially had their own god that they
claimed was the best god the god of the
city of babylon was called marduk so one
day this great council of gods got
together and they were like oh no tiamat
is coming tiamat was the abyss the
endless the oldest god who came before
all other gods much like tiamat and the
celestials so this babylonian god marduk
fights tiamat and the old goddess opens
her mouth to swallow him whole but while
he's inside her belly he dismembers her
from the inside and creates the earth
and heavens from her body now the
eternals has a lot of themes about old
gods new gods and different human
attitudes towards gods throughout the
centuries so this ending fits perfectly
with that theme the eternals fight and
destroy their old god transforming it
into something new and creating a new
order for the universe just like marduk
crafted the heavens and the earth from
the body of an old god tiamat
anyways i hope you enjoyed that fact
about the eternals you can go back to
being really bad at your job
thanks for that ryan now if you haven't
left the video because he's such a [ __ ]
isn't he's such an idiot then the other
ancient landmarks include the great wall
of india and we see cersei and icarus
getting it on and getting married if you
watch this scene in imax you can
actually see the tip going in and
stop the video i could stop recording i
can't put that in the video thanks now
at the wedding we get a shot of the rest
of the group who all look happy that the
pair tied the knot this is except for
sprite who we can see at the front
looking more miserable than i do trying
to be a dc fan throughout the film we
learned that she's actually in love with
igorous so this explains why she's so
devastated icarus always saw her as a
child who'd never grow up and she also
gets called tinkerbell at one point this
is of course a nod to the peter pan
story a tale about a boy who never grew
up which sprite actually inspired in the
comics they travel out to south dakota
and you can actually see one of the
earthquake lines in the ground now after
going to ajax cersei ends up getting the
sphere from her corpse you can actually
see the lines in her skin which are
similar the lines of the eternals and
she doesn't rot like a normal person
would as we learn the eternals are in
fact synthetic and thus her being like
this shows that she's more machine than
man
or woman cheers for that obi-wan now we
then go back to 1521 to see the capital
of the aztec empire being ransacked by
the conquistadors this is something that
actually happened in real life and it
pretty much splits the group up dina
suffers mad weary which we discover is
the memories coming back from the
planets that they destroyed during the
birth cycle of a celestial she mentioned
century 6 which is actually a planet
from the comics that ended up getting
enslaved
everyone in century 6 is going to die
give me your hand it's too late
we can't save them
he ends up leaving the group which was
somewhat murdered in the comics in which
he left them to go off with crow later
on in the movie crow and thena end up in
a cave together and this might be a nod
to a panel from the comics in which the
pair kissed in one doesn't really happen
in the movie but you know we like a good
reach here now we also meet kingo in the
future who's shooting a film based on
the legend of icarus and the costume he
has actually looks like the bollywood
version of his suit you also meet his
assistant karoon who's referred to as
alfred which is of course a nod to dc
dad that's superman ted that's superman
jack that's really funny jack that is
definitely not super superman i saw him
on tv superman is also mentioned at 1.2
and chloe zhao actually said in
interviews that man of steel had a major
influence on icarus now kingo talks
about how karoon thought he was a
vampire at first and this could be
foreshadowing blade's arrival later on
vampires of course don't age and because
of this he's been able to build an
acting dynasty gilgamesh and kingo both
discuss odin and the latter also brings
up thor saying that he used to follow
him around
speaking of voting story used to follow
me around when he was a little kid now
he's a famous adventurer and won't
return my calls kingo says that he won't
return his calls now and as we learn in
thor ragnarok the guy just tends to send
things by electronic letter it's called
an email now sprite brings up captain
rogers iron man and the avengers so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone who do you think's gonna lead
the avengers
i could lead them the name captain
rogers to describe steve is pretty
interesting i think it's because sam
wilson is of course captain america at
this point we learn more about the truth
of aeroshim which involves the
celestials rising out of the ocean and
so far in the mcu this hasn't really
been addressed now it is possible that
this could tie into the events of black
panther 2 which we know will be debuting
neymar in avengers end game we heard
about underwater earthquakes from akoye
and it is possible that tmrising will
cause the kingdom to come up to the
surface the eternals then go to visit
druid and after learning that the planet
could be destroyed cersei told stein to
bury the hatchet with his uncle this of
course sets up the black knight plot
that we talked about earlier and the
deviants attack cersei transforms one
into a tree and though she initially
believed that she couldn't do this in
the same way that she's breaking from
the path that arishon put her on she's
also realizing that having this one
fixed belief system has helped her back
we also get more of crowe who sadly
isn't as developed as he's in the comics
as well as flashbacks of hiroshima this
involved the us military dropping a nuke
that killed 129 thousand people and this
was later followed up with one being
dropped on nagasaki that killed 226 000
it's currently the only two times that
nuclear weapons have been used in war
and fast cells clearly regrets helping
humanity be able to carry out this level
of destruction i did this fast does
regretting his development of the atomic
bomb was somewhat mirrored in its
real-life creator robert oppenheimer who
was very vocal about how much he wished
he'd never helped to create it fastos
also helped to develop the plow and
though it's played off as a joke this
device was actually integral in moving
humanity into the bronze age shout out
to ryanairy again for that one actually
shut the [ __ ] up ryanairy although he
regretted this fastus found love and
icarus and cersei end up going inside
his house icarus suspects that
everything is fortified including a
table which he believes could be made
out of vibranium a further nod to black
panther they then return to the ruins of
babylon and bring the domo up from the
ground they call makari miss havisham a
recluse from the book great expectations
who was jilted at the altar she spent
the rest of her life in her wedding
dress and she lived in a ruined mansion
hoarding several items much in the same
way that makari does other items that we
didn't mention earlier include a
playstation vr and also a big mac which
about the height of modern culture
fastas also comes up with the idea of
uni mind which is a name i think they
care because it shows up in the comics
like most names like this that show up
in live action they talk about how [ __ ]
it is because hey that's just what they
do in these movies uni meaning one mind
meaning mine oh no we heard you the
first terrible brainstorm
brainstorm that's a win no i invented it
so i'm calling it whatever i want the
truth is revealed and this leads into
the final battle but just before it we
can catch the aqueduct in italy and the
christ the redeemer statue that's
located in rio mukari is also wearing an
hg world's war of the worlds t-shirt
which was of course about aliens coming
to earth to destroy it much like this
movie kingo ends up leaving because [ __ ]
karoon and i was kind of hoping that
he'd show up like han solo did during
the final battle but unfortunately he
doesn't stella it's a pretty solid
action scene and after athena defeats
crow the eternals put their differences
aside and transform tiamat into marble
during this battle icarus also fires his
eye lasers into the sky in anger which
is a nod to the cover of the eternals
issue 6. after the battle he flies into
the sun which potentially may have been
an idea that was planted into his head
by sprite and the legend that's not me
talking about you by the way when i say
legend there you sucker anyway cersei
turns up i'm so sorry i love you guys
you know i do appreciate you guys
supporting the channel i know i keep
calling you suckers all the time but you
mean the world to me and i don't know
what i'd do if you went away please come
back anyway cersei turns sprite into a
human somewhat referencing pinocchio and
this shot of their hands touching to
create something new is of course
mirrored in the opening of the movie
when the former hands the blade over the
eternal split up and some go into space
which we'll talk about in a bit harishm
summons the remaining ones and he tells
them that he will judge whether the
planet should be destroyed or not in the
comics arishim was known as arish and
the judge and he's finally living up to
his name here
[Music]
should just destroy mate i'll save you
the time
destroy it the post credit scene
introduces aeros the brother of thanos
along with pip the troll voiced by pat
oswalt he was a member of his home
planet's royal family that used to whine
and dine all the time in 69 however one
day he drank an enchanted drink and was
turned into a troll he's typically
associated with adam warlock who was
teased at the end of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 and he even acted as a
guardian to the space stone at one point
brother of thanos the knave of hearts
defeater
of black robert roger
now he brings a black roger and mystery
planet but i think this might just be
another dark roger who was the leader of
that planet in the comics in the comics
he was defeated by eros so i think it's
kind of painting out his backstory a bit
they just got the name wrong because pip
is probably drunk the way they teleport
in also comes with several colours which
is of course something that is seen when
one uses the bifrost as ferraros or
rather star fox he's someone who can
manipulate the emotions of others and
because of this it's possible that he
can have people in complete ecstasy due
to his abilities he's known as quite the
lover but it has caused some controversy
in a she-hulk story he was accused of
using his powers to make women sleep
with him but i think stuff like that
will just be completely ignored by
disney which is fair enough as he's not
exactly a role model like your uncle
kevin spoilers because i love you guys
like i said now the fact that he's the
brother of thanos begs the question
whether thanos who was a deviant eternal
himself knew of the celestial's plans
there is potential that he wiped out
half of all life to stop maturing
planets from being destroyed but i'll
leave that up to you to argue about in
the comments now as a thank you for
coming in you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of january in
which we're giving away three copies of
an mcu boxer of your choice all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of chongqi which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
all the easter eggs in it and the comic
book history so definitely go check it
out right after this without the way
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been poor let's see in the next one
take care peace